.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Die Kriminellen, die sich
im Internet tummeln, sind gnadenlos.
Sie tat mir schon leid,
weil ich ihr alles genommen habe.
Manchmal fühlt man sich schlecht.
Aber nicht sehr.
Und dann steht man mit zerplatztem
Traum da - Liebe weg, Geld weg -
und fragt sich: "Was jetzt?"
Online-Liebesbetrug -
eine besonders fiese Masche.
Das Internet hat
die Hemmschwelle generell gesenkt.
Mit Verbrechen im Netz
wurden im letzten Jahr
1,5 Billionen Dollar umgesetzt.
(Mann) Kolumbianisches Kokain, 85 %.
Hier findet man wirklich alles.
Wir tauchen ein ins Darknet
und blicken in Abgründe.
Was findet man hier? - Hier
bieten sich Auftragsmörder an.
Verbrechen im Netz
machen vor keinen Grenzen halt.
Für pädosexuelle Straftäter
hat sich eine neue Welt aufgetan.
(Frau) Das ist Daddy Louis.
Ihm wurden 70 Fälle nachgewiesen,
in denen er Kinder fotografiert hat.
Wir zeigen
die globalen Zusammenhänge auf
und die Schwierigkeiten der Polizei,
mit den Kriminellen im Internet
Schritt zu halten.
Accra, die Hauptstadt Ghanas.
Ghana gilt neben Nigeria
als Hotspot für Liebesschwindler.
Sog. Love Scammer machen online Geld
mit falscher Liebe.
So wie Michael.
Mit 15 fing er an mit dem Scammen,
heute ist er 27 und ein Profi.
Du musst dich stets an jedes Detail
erinnern, das du gesagt hast.
Du darfst nie dieselbe Geschichte
für alle Frauen verwenden.
Es kommt darauf an,
wie viel Geld die Klientin hat.
Wenn du mehr als vier Frauen hast,
wirst du verrückt.
Michael chattet meistens
mit Frauen aus den USA.
Da gibt es keine Sprachprobleme.
Kannst du mir
was zu trinken bringen?
Das Ziel der Scammer ist es,
die Bedürfnisse der Frauen zu
verstehen und sie an sich zu binden.
Du versuchst,
durch konstante Kommunikation
in ihr Leben einzudringen.
Sie muss glauben, dass du
der Einzige bist, den sie hat.
Du schreibst ihr jeden Morgen,
kaufst ihr Blumen oder Pizza.
Echte Blumen?
- Ja, echte Blumen.
Die werden
zu ihr nach Hause geliefert.
Oder Pizza, die sie essen können.
Erst dann glauben sie,
dass es wahr ist.
Aufmerksamkeiten, die ankommen.
Michaels Handy
ist voll mit Liebesbekundungen.
Michaels Antwort:
Viele Opfer bindet er
Monate oder Jahre an sich.
Um sie rumzukriegen,
benutzt er die Identität
eines australischen Unternehmers.
Ich speichere seine Bilder
nicht auf meinem Handy,
weil die Polizei das kontrolliert,
wenn sie dich erwischt.
Aber hier ist er. Das ist der Mann.
Er heisst Joe Kross,
gibt im Internet Gesundheitstipps
und ist ebenfalls Opfer.
Seine Fotos
benutze ich für alle meine Frauen.
Zürich.
Hier wohnt ein Opfer
eines Liebesbetruges: Nicole Flury.
Während des Corona-Shutdowns
fühlte sich die Unternehmerin einsam
und suchte auf Tinder
nach einem Partner.
Und dann tauchte sein Bild auf
und es machte: "Bam!"
Ich dachte,
das Schicksal habe zugeschlagen
und ich hätte
meinen Traummann gefunden.
So ist es passiert.
Sie wechselten bald
von Tinder auf WhatsApp.
Der Kontakt mit dem Traummann
wurde schnell vertraut und intensiv.
Ich fühlte mich von ihm gesehen.
Er hat mich auch
aus dieser "Einsamkeit" gerissen,
die ich beschrieb -
Corona, allein,
draussen grau und regnerisch ...
Und dann taucht auf einmal
jemand auf, der dich fragt,
wie es dir geht, was du vorhast
und der mit dir connecten möchte.
Er brachte wieder Leben
in mein Leben.
Der Scammer wusste genau,
was sie hören wollte.
Aus einem Flirt wurde schnell Liebe.
Virtuelle Herzen flogen hin und her.
Eine Explosion der Gefühle.
Er schaffte es wirklich ...
... mich sehr schnell
an sich zu binden
und grosses Vertrauen aufzubauen.
Auch durch sein Profil:
selbstständig, reist gerne ...
Er sagte auch schnell,
dass er gut situiert sei
und ich mir keine Gedanken
für die Zukunft machen müsste.
Das beruhigt uns Frauen
jeweils schon auch.
David Leroux nannte er sich.
Angeblich Unternehmer
und amerikanisch-französischer
Doppelbürger.
David Leroux heisst in Wahrheit
Martin Melin, ist 55,
von Beruf Polizist
und lebt in Stockholm.
Es gibt Tausende von Konten,
die mit meinen Bildern
eingerichtet wurden,
auf allen möglichen Plattformen:
Tinder, Facebook, Instagram
und noch auf vielen anderen,
die es nur im Ausland gibt.
Ja, leider,
ich bin mir dessen sehr bewusst.
Was macht das mit Ihnen?
Logisch beeinflusst es mich.
Ich bekomme täglich Nachrichten
von Frauen, die reingelegt wurden.
Ich lese ihre Erfahrungen,
ich leide mit ihnen.
Gewisse Frauen denken,
es sei mein Fehler,
dass ich das stoppen muss,
dass ich etwas machen muss.
Aber ich bin machtlos.
Ich kann es nicht stoppen.
Ich kann nichts dagegen tun.
Es macht mich traurig
für diese Frauen, leider.
Martin Melin ist in Schweden
eine bekannte Persönlichkeit.
Neben seiner Arbeit als Polizist
sitzt er für die Liberalen
im nationalen Parlament, wo er sich
u.a. für Frauenrechte engagiert.
Und er ist
eine Fernsehpersönlichkeit.
Er nahm etwa
an der schwedischen Version
von "Dancing with the Stars" teil.
Wer seine Bilder missbrauchen will,
findet Tausende davon im Internet.
Wir müssen die Menschen
besser informieren.
Aber wir alle müssen auch
mehr Eigenverantwortung tragen.
Sie könnten sich doch einfach
von sozialen Medien zurückziehen?
Ja, ich könnte natürlich aufhören,
Bilder hochzuladen.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass dies
die Lösung des Problems ist.
Es gibt andere Männer, deren Bilder
diese Leute benutzen können.
Liebesschwindel gab es schon immer,
aber so einfach wie heute
war er noch nie.
Christine Brand
setzt sich als Gerichtsreporterin
und Krimiautorin
täglich mit Verbrechen auseinander.
Das Internet sei ein Segen
für Kriminelle, sagt sie.
Man muss weniger
kriminelle Energie aufwenden,
um an Dinge zu kommen, die vorher
doch einiges an Wissen bedurften.
Das Internet ist für Täter eine Art
Selbstbedienungsladen geworden -
sei das für Drogenhandel,
Waffen oder Kinderpornografie.
Es ist ein Stück weit
ein rechtsfreier Raum geworden,
weil es schwierig ist, im Internet
jemandem auf die Spur zu kommen.
Stimmt das?
Diese Frage trage ich in die
Redaktionsräume von SRF Investigativ,
sozusagen
unser Recherche-Hauptquartier.
Ich bitte den Journalisten
Philippe Stalder,
für diesen Film ins Internet hinter
dem Internet, ins sog. Darknet,
einzutauchen, um herauszufinden,
ob dort wirklich alles zu haben ist
und wie lange es dauert,
bis er es findet.
Stalders Reise ins Darknet beginnt
zusammen mit einem Redaktionskollegen
und einem speziellen Browser.
Hier ist jeder anonym unterwegs.
Darum können sich Leute im Iran
oder in China bei der BBC
oder der "New York Times" informieren
und so die Zensur umgehen.
Aber es findet sich
auch ganz anderes.
(Philippe Stalder)
Kolumbianisches Kokain, 85 %.
"Columbian Cocaine Untouched".
"Origin Country United States,
ships to United States".
Krass, mit nur zwei Klicks ...
Wenn wir in den USA leben würden,
wären wir ...
Ja, und man findet ...
- ... schon dran.
Ja, und das
findet man auch in der Schweiz.
Hier findet man wirklich alles.
Das Angebot reicht von Drogen
bis zu Followern
und Klicks in sozialen Medien.
3 Dollar für 1'000 Views.
Es ist krass,
wie breit das Angebot ist.
Bezahlt wird mit Kryptowährungen -
ganz anonym.
Man ist also halbwegs geschützt.
- Wenn du ...
Kurz darauf ist Philippe Stalders
erste Bestellung aus dem Darknet
eingetroffen: eine unregistrierte
SIM-Karte fürs Mobiltelefon
wurde ihm problemlos
an seine Privatadresse geliefert.
Unregistrierte SIM-Karten
eigenen sich für Handlungen,
von denen man nicht möchte,
dass sie zurückverfolgt werden.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass ein Drogendealer
seine Bestellungen über
eine solche SIM-Karte abwickelt
oder darüber Bestellungen aufnimmt.
Oder aber Personen, die einen
Kinderpornografie-Ring aufbauen -
die sind vielleicht auch froh,
wenn sie sich über einen Kanal
austauschen können, der sich nicht
zurückverfolgen lässt.
Kinderpornografie - ein riesiges
Geschäft, das stetig wächst.
Produziert
wird diese verbotene Pornografie
in Ländern wie den Philippinen.
Die Zahlen von sexuellem Missbrauch
von Kindern fürs Internet
sind hier in den letzten Jahren
explodiert.
Esther Bühlmann,
eine Sozialarbeiterin aus Bern,
reiste 2016 zum ersten Mal
nach Cagayan de Oro,
im Süden der Philippinen.
Inzwischen lebt sie hier und hat
ein eigenes Hilfswerk gegründet,
das sich
um Kinderprostituierte kümmert.
Kinderprostitution hat in der Regel
eine lange Vorgeschichte -
zu Hause oder im Umfeld.
Eine Vorgeschichte mit Missbrauch,
auch für illegale Pornografie.
Oft beginnt es zu Hause.
Und das führt dann dazu, dass sie
nicht mehr gerne zu Hause sind,
weil sie gezwungen werden, sexuelle
Aktivitäten mit ihren Geschwistern,
Eltern oder wem auch immer
vor der Kamera zu vollführen.
Also laufen sie von zu Hause weg.
Zudem zeigen Studien, dass Kinder,
die zu Hause
sexuell missbraucht wurden,
ein grösseres Risiko haben,
in der Prostitution zu landen.
Esther Bühlmann kümmert sich also
sozusagen um die Langzeitfolgen
von Misshandlungen und Missbrauch.
Kinderpornografie
landet über das World Wide Web
bei Männern auf der ganzen Welt.
Die Opfer bleiben indes hier
und leiden oft ein Leben lang.
Vernetzung
ist auch bei der Bekämpfung
dieses komplexen Problems zentral.
Esther Bühlmann arbeitet darum
mit verschiedenen NGOs zusammen.
Eine davon besucht sie heute: BALAOD.
BALAOD stellt Opfern
gratis Anwälte zur Verfügung,
die ihre Interessen vor Gericht
und gegenüber Behörden vertreten.
Gemeinsam
gelingen immer wieder Erfolge.
Das ist Daddy Louis.
Seinen richtigen Namen
kenne ich nicht.
Ihm wurden 70 Fälle nachgewiesen, in
denen er Kinder fotografiert hat -
nackt oder
in irgendwelchen sexuellen Posen.
Diese Fotos hat er dann verbreitet.
Das sind die bekannten Fälle,
aber es gibt noch viel mehr.
Sie haben ihn vor
ungefähr zwei Jahren festgenommen.
Er wartet jetzt auf seinen Prozess
und muss wohl
mit lebenslänglich rechnen.
Der Anwalt Perfecto Justino Mendoza
hat sich auf Fälle
von Kinderpornografie spezialisiert.
How are you?
- Good, thank you. You?
Das Phänomen habe sich verändert,
stellt er fest.
In der Vergangenheit ...
... waren es hauptsächlich
Ausländer:
Japaner, Australier und Amerikaner,
die wegen solcher Delikte
strafrechtlich verfolgt wurden.
Aber in den vergangenen Jahren
haben wir es zunehmend
mit den Eltern der Kinder zu tun,
denn die haben gemerkt,
dass sie viel Geld verdienen können,
indem sie ihre Kinder
vor einer Kamera tanzen
oder Sex haben lassen
und das online stellen.
Der Hauptgrund ist Armut.
Wenn du hungrig bist
und dir wird
die Möglichkeit geboten,
im Internet mit Kinderpornografie
Geld zu machen,
dann ist das eine Option
für arme Menschen.
Thank you, goodbye.
- Thank you for coming.
Für pädosexuelle Straftäter
hat sich eine neue Welt aufgetan,
denn es ist viel einfacher geworden,
Straftaten zu begehen.
Die Straftäter
können sich vernetzen,
im Internet und im Darknet
Material beziehen.
Im Darknet
soll es ja sogar möglich sein,
Live-Missbrauch von Kindern
irgendwo auf der Welt zu bestellen.
Früher war es für
pädosexuelle Personen schwieriger,
sich untereinander zu vernetzen.
Zudem brauchten sie
einen direkten Kontakt zum Kind,
um einen Kindesmissbrauch
zu begehen.
Dank des Internets ist es heute
für sie viel einfacher geworden,
sich zu vernetzen, sich
über Kontinente hinweg zu verabreden
oder aber auch über Kontinente
hinweg Kinder zu missbrauchen.
Die USA spielen eine Schlüsselrolle
im Kampf gegen Kinderpornografie.
Hier tätige Tech-Unternehmen
sind verpflichtet,
entsprechende Inhalte
bei Kenntnis zu melden.
Diese Meldungen
landen beim National Center
for Missing and Exploited Children,
kurz NCMEC.
Im vergangenen Jahr
gingen hier 30 Mio. Fälle ein.
Zwei Drittel kamen von Facebook,
der Rest von anderen Unternehmen
aus dem Social-Media-Bereich,
die die Chats ihrer User monitoren.
John Shehan ist Vizepräsident
der Abteilung Exploited Children
bei NCMEC.
Die Verdachtsfälle
würden hier gesammelt
und an die Herkunftsländer der Täter
verteilt.
Wir arbeiten selbstverständlich auch
mit der Schweizer Polizei zusammen.
Wir machen ihnen
unsere Informationen zugänglich.
Von den 30 Mio. Verdachtsfällen,
die wir letztes Jahr erhalten haben,
reichten wir gut 7'000 weiter
an die Schweiz.
Wir bieten Unterstützung bei der
Interpretation und der Triage an.
Am Ende
ist es an den Schweizer Behörden,
diese Meldungen zu überprüfen
und zu entscheiden,
ob die geltenden Gesetze
verletzt werden
und ob ermittelt werden soll.
Diese Daten
landen in der Schweiz bei NEDIK,
beim Netzwerk digitale Ermittlungs-
unterstützung Internetkriminalität.
Vor zwei Jahren schlossen sich
alle Schweizer Polizeikorps
zu NEDIK zusammen,
um die Kräfte zu bündeln.
Der Präsident von NEDIK
ist auch Cybercrime-Chef
der Kantonspolizei Zürich.
Serdar Günal Rütsche ist damit der
höchste Cyberpolizist der Schweiz.
Er erklärt, was mit den Meldungen
aus den USA passiert.
Die Meldungen von NCMEC durchlaufen
bei uns zwei Filterstellen.
Zunächst filtern wir zentral
für die ganze Schweiz heraus,
was gemäss Schweizer Gesetz
strafbar ist.
Das leiten wir den Kantonen weiter,
die den Inhalt dann nochmals
mit ihrer Staatsanwaltschaft prüfen.
Und wenn die Staatsanwaltschaft
entscheidet,
Massnahmen zu ergreifen,
können wir sicher sein,
dass es ein strafbarer Inhalt ist.
Die Diskussion rund um das Monitoring
von sozialen Medien
hat inzwischen Bundesbern erreicht.
Die Schweiz
übernimmt die Meldungen aus den USA.
Hierzulande überwacht indes niemand
das Internet systematisch.
Judith Bellaiche betont,
sie verabscheue Pädokriminalität.
Aber sie engagiert sich entschieden
gegen das flächendeckende
Durchleuchten von Chats.
Die meisten Menschen
sind unbescholten
und haben noch nie in ihrem Leben
etwas Falsches gemacht.
All diese Menschen
über ihre Smartphones
und Tablets zu überwachen,
wäre in etwa so,
wie wenn man bei allen täglich
eine Hausdurchsuchung machen würde,
um zu prüfen, ob sie zu Hause
nicht ein Kind vergewaltigen.
Das wäre absurd
und unverhältnismässig.
Unverhältnismässige
Massenüberwachung?
Oder dringend nötig?
Wenn es technisch möglich ist,
dann muss man das auch tun.
Sie haben also keine Bedenken?
- Nein, denn sowohl auf die Technik
als auch auf die Strafverfolgung
in der Schweiz ist Verlass.
Was sagen Sie Menschen,
die das als Massenüberwachung sehen?
Nicht die Masse wird überwacht,
sondern festgestellt,
welche verbotenen Dinge
ausgetauscht werden.
Nicht der Inhalt
wird also überwacht,
sondern es werden gezielt
die verbotenen Dinge herausgepickt.
Wer nichts zu verbergen hat,
habe nichts zu befürchten.
In anderen Staaten sehen wir,
worauf das hinausläuft:
Hat der Staat erst mal Zugriff
auf die gesamte Privatsphäre,
dann nutzt er sie auch
für andere Zwecke
als nur zur Verfolgung
von Pädokriminalität.
Deswegen müssen wir Grenzen setzen.
Zurück in den USA.
John Shehan von der Abteilung
Exploited Children bei NCMEC
führt uns ins Herzstück
seiner Organisation.
Hier arbeiten zwei Teams:
Ein Team
nimmt die Meldungen entgegen,
das andere identifiziert Opfer.
Der Zugang ist eingeschränkt
wegen des sensiblen Materials,
mit dem wir hier arbeiten.
Hier gilt
die höchste Sicherheitsstufe.
Hier lagern
beschlagnahmte Beweismittel.
Wenn die Strafverfolgungsbehörden
jemanden verhaften
in einem Fall von Kindesmissbrauch,
dann bekommen wir eine Kopie,
damit wir versuchen können,
die Opfer zu identifizieren.
Für NCMEC ist klar:
Der Erfolg
gibt dem Monitoring recht.
Böse Menschen, die sexuelles
Interesse an Kindern haben,
tauschen sich miteinander aus,
offen oder im Darknet.
Sie zeigen einander, wie man
seine Identität verschleiert.
Aber sie beobachten auch Provider
und Plattformen -
ob diese versuchen
oder nicht versuchen,
solche Aktivitäten
zu identifizieren.
Die wissen,
wo die für sie sicheren Häfen sind,
und dorthin werden sie
ihre Aktivitäten verlagern.
Mit anderen Worten:
Die Schweiz könnte
zu einem sicheren Hafen werden,
wenn hierzulande weiterhin niemand
das Internet systematisch überwacht.
Mit solchen Erpressungsversuchen
müssen wir vorsichtig umgehen.
In den USA werden Kinder
in der Schule erschossen,
weil die USA ein sicherer Hafen sind
für Waffenfreiheit und Waffengewalt.
Deshalb denke ich, dass wir
unsere Strafverfolgungsbehörden
seriös arbeiten
und uns von solchen Druckversuchen
nicht zu stark
beeinflussen lassen sollten.
Philippe Stalder von SRF Investigativ
konnte im Darknet problemlos eine
unregistrierte SIM-Karte bestellen.
Seine Recherche zeigt indes:
Je verbotener etwas ist,
desto länger braucht es,
bis man Zugang dazu erhält.
Persönliche Beziehungen
sind meistens ausschlaggebend.
Je nachdem,
wie nischenhaft ein Forum ist
und ob man sich im entsprechenden
Kreis beliebt machen kann,
indem man z.B.
gewisse Informationen teilt
und Vertrauen und damit
auch Beziehungen aufbauen kann,
wird man
zu exklusiven Foren eingeladen.
Das braucht aber sehr viel Zeit.
Philippe Stalder
macht sich auf den Weg zu einem,
der solche Kreise
beruflich infiltriert.
Er trifft Marc Ruef
von der Firma Scip AG,
einem Unternehmen
im Bereich Cybersecurity.
Ruef leitet die Forschungsabteilung,
die für Behörden und Firmen
Darknet-Monitorings durchführt.
Ein täglicher Blick in Abgründe.
"Preis für ein menschliches Baby
aus China" ...
7'800 Dollar
kostet ein Baby aus China.
1'200 Dollar zahlt man
für einen echten menschlichen Schädel
inklusive Zähne.
Und 400 Dollar für eine AK-47,
eine Kalaschnikow.
Wenn ich eine AK-47 bestellen würde:
Kann ich mir die einfach von
der Post nach Hause liefern lassen
oder wie läuft das logistisch
genau ab?
Abgesehen davon,
dass ich es nicht empfehlen würde,
weil es rechtlich verboten ist ...
- Rein hypothetisch.
Die meisten wickeln es
über "tote" Briefkästen ab.
Wenn z.B. ein Briefkasten
in einer Überbauung leer steht,
wird temporär
ein fiktives Namensschild montiert,
und die Ware wird dorthin geliefert,
wo sie dann abgeholt wird.
Was sehen wir hier genau?
Hier bieten sich
verschiedene Auftragsmörder an.
Bei unserer Analyse ist es wichtig,
zu identifizieren,
was echt ist und was nicht.
5'000 Euro verlangt Blacklord,
der schon über 100 Leute
getötet haben will.
Er bringt Menschen ab 16 um,
Geschlecht egal.
Langes Leiden bietet er an,
auch Fotos und Videos der Tat.
Er arbeitet in Europa,
Asien und Afrika.
Diese Seite sei wohl ein Fake,
sagt Marc Ruef.
V.a. die tiefen Preise
machen ihn stutzig.
In der Schweiz sei ein Auftragsmord
wesentlich teurer.
In der Schweiz
kostet ein Auftragsmord 400'000 Fr.
Heisst das also,
dass es hier einen Fall gab?
Da sind diese Fälle enthalten.
Das bedeutet nicht,
dass ich in der Schweiz
z.B. innerhalb von einer Woche
jemanden finden kann,
der für dieses Geld
einen Auftragsmord ausführt.
Aber ja, es gab Menschen,
die für Geld gewisse Dinge machten.
Unendlich viele Angebote,
unendlich tiefe Abgründe -
das ist das Darknet.
Für die Polizei ist es schwierig,
Schritt zu halten -
einerseits
aufgrund des sehr grossen Spektrums
und weil sich sehr viel Täter
im Netz tummeln.
Andererseits ist es auch schwierig,
die Spuren im Netz zu verfolgen,
wenn sich jemand mit den richtigen
Schutzvorrichtungen im Netz bewegt.
Präventiv zu wirken ...
Umso wichtiger sei die Prävention
in Sachen Cybercrime,
betont die Polizei,
gerade bei jungen Leuten.
Ortstermin
in einer Berufsschule im Baselbiet.
Die Kriminellen
hinter gewissen Angeboten sind ...
... absolut gnadenlos.
Sie werden z.B. auf Instagram
von einer gut aussehenden
jungen Frau angeschrieben.
Es kommt zu einem Dialog, eine
Online-Freundschaft entwickelt sich.
Und irgendwann
fordert Sie die junge Dame auf,
sich auszuziehen und sexuelle
Handlungen an sich vorzunehmen.
Sie tut es Ihnen gleich.
Und danach verschwindet
die junge Dame, denn sie ist fake,
die gibt es so gar nicht.
Danach melden sich die Täter,
die dahinterstecken,
und erpressen Sie mit der Aufnahme:
"Wenn du uns nicht 400 Fr. bezahlst,
werden wir das Video
veröffentlichen."
Sextortion nennt sich das,
Online-Erpressung.
Auch diese Zahlen steigen rasant.
Die Opfer sind v.a. junge Männer.
Auch in der Schweiz werden wir
noch mehr Kriminelle haben,
die das Internet
als Arbeitsfeld entdecken.
Wir werden vermehrt
mit leichten, mittleren
und schweren Delikten zu tun haben.
Wir werden als Gesellschaft
noch viel fitter werden müssen,
um gegen Cyberkriminalität
gewappnet zu sein.
Wir sind noch längst nicht dort,
wo wir sein müssten.
Bei Frauen mittleren Alters
ist derzeit v.a. Liebesbetrug
ein grosses Thema.
Nicole Flury lernte ihren vermeint-
lichen Traummann auf Tinder kennen
und verliebte sich Hals über Kopf.
Nach einem Monat
war er auf Geschäftsreise
und brauchte dringend Geld,
weil seins blockiert sei.
Ich sagte ihm,
dass er doch als Geschäftsmann
bestimmt einen Juristen
oder jemand anderen haben müsse,
der ihm helfen könne.
Seine Frau sei zwar verstoben,
aber er habe doch bestimmt Freunde,
Geschäftskollegen, irgendjemanden.
Und in stoischer Ruhe besprach er
all meine Zweifel mit mir durch
und hatte
für jeden meiner Zweifel ...
... ein greifbares
und realistisches Gegenargument.
Und irgendwann, nachdem wir eine
Stunde darüber diskutiert hatten,
kam ich zum Schluss, dass es
keine andere Möglichkeit gab.
Nach der ersten Überweisung wurde
die Geschichte immer dramatischer:
Er sei angeschossen worden
und ringe mit dem Tod.
Er müsse dringend operiert werden,
aber das Krankenhaus
behandle ihn erst,
wenn er Bares auf den Tisch lege.
Alles in allem 31'000 Euro.
Und wieder diskutierte ich mit ihm.
Er meinte, ob ich einen Teil
übernehmen könnte,
und er würde wegen des Rests
mit jemand anderem schauen.
Er war schon auch
immer recht kooperativ.
Ich sagte nie zu ihm: "Aber gerne,
ich schicke dir das Geld."
Er musste das jedes Mal
mit mir aushandeln, diskutieren
und sich darum bemühen,
sich auch um Alternativen bemühen.
Aber letztlich wollte ich ihm dann
doch wieder helfen.
Wie das dann eben so ist.
Sie haben einen dann fest am Haken.
Accra, die Hauptstadt Ghanas.
Wie Nicole Flurys Scammer
lebt auch Michael in Westafrika.
Frauen aus der ganzen Welt
überweisen ihm Geld -
bis sie nichts mehr haben.
In diesem Fall
sollten es 1'000 Dollar sein.
Sie hat mir zuerst 700
und dann noch mal 300 überwiesen.
Wenn die Frau irgendwann pleite ist,
brichst du den Kontakt nicht ab,
sondern findest einen Weg,
sie weiter auszunutzen.
Das habe ich mit dieser Frau
auch so gemacht.
Eine Frau überliess Michael
ihr ganzes Vermögen,
verkaufte sogar ihr Haus.
Heute lebt sie von staatlicher Hilfe.
Sie konnte nichts mehr kaufen
und brauchte Essensmarken.
Sie tat mir schon leid,
weil ich ihr alles genommen habe.
Manchmal fühlt man sich schlecht.
Aber nicht sehr.
Sein geringes Schuldgefühl erklärt er
mit den über drei Jahrhunderte
andauernden Verbrechen
westlicher Kolonialherren.
Wir glauben, dass wir als Sklaven
mit unserem Schweiss
eure Länder aufgebaut haben.
Ihr habt ein gutes Leben
und wir leiden.
Ausserdem habt ihr uns Gold
und Edelsteine gestohlen.
Wir haben das Gefühl,
uns etwas zurückholen zu müssen.
Diese Scammer und Scammerinnen
verstehen es,
Menschen
auf subtile Art zu manipulieren.
Im Grund genommen
ist man ihre Marionette
und macht, wie sie einem befehlen.
Da ist gewissermassen
etwas in der Luft,
das einen ausser Gefecht setzt.
Das Ganze
ist schon irgendwie auch spooky.
Heute hat Michael
etwas ganz Besonderes vor.
Alle Scammer, die ich kenne,
all meine Freunde,
gehen zu einem Voodoo-Priester, weil
die Klientinnen widerspenstig sind.
Reich, aber widerspenstig.
Die würden dir normalerweise
nicht einen Dollar schicken.
Also müssen wir die Sache
selbst in die Hand nehmen.
Voodoo -
oder auch Black Magic genannt -
ist die ursprüngliche Religion
in Ghana.
Das Christentum brachten erst
die Kolonialmächte ins Land.
Für viele Menschen haben die alten
Zauberkräfte eine grosse Bedeutung.
Das gehört zu unserer Kultur.
Wir sind damit aufgewachsen.
So, wie wir an Gott glauben,
glauben wir auch an diese Dinge.
Gott ändert die Sachen nicht sofort,
aber Voodoo
funktioniert innert weniger Tage.
Der Priester
residiert in einer Hütte am Strand.
Für Michael
ist der Besuch eine Investition.
Bezahlt wird,
wenn das Ritual erfolgreich ist
und die Frau überweist.
Darum geht es.
Mit dem Zauber der Liebe
hat das nichts zu tun.
Das ist die Klientin,
von der ich erzählt habe.
Sie will nicht zahlen.
Ich will,
dass du mit deiner Magie hilfst.
Wo kommt sie her?
- Aus den USA.
Weisst du, wie sie heisst?
- Ja.
Was möchtest du von ihr?
Ich möchte, dass sie mir zuhört
und alles tut, was ich sage.
Ich wurde spirituell geboren.
Das Geheimnis unserer Kräfte
basiert auf unseren Vorfahren -
im Gegensatz
zu den heutigen Priestern.
Die können nie
die gleiche Kraft besitzen wie ich.
Das ist kein Vergleich.
Du bist willkommen. Nimm das Bild.
Jetzt wird das Bild der Frau
um den sog. Spirit gewickelt.
Zeig ihm, wie es geht,
aber lass es ihn selbst machen.
Michael soll
eine bestimmte Knüpftechnik anwenden.
Als Nächstes
kommt Ziegenblut zum Einsatz.
Heb das hoch.
Sag ihren Namen.
Naomi, Naomi.
Jetzt heb es hoch ...
... und lass es fallen.
Habt ihr die Funken gesehen?
Die sollen die Wahrnehmung der Frau
blenden, damit sie mir gehorcht.
Um ganz sicher zu sein,
zaubert der Priester
noch eine weitere Göttin aus dem Hut.
Viel hilft viel.
Wir fragen die Königin der Meere
um ihre Erlaubnis,
uns das Licht zu geben
und seine Bitten
wahr werden zu lassen.
Ein Voodoo-Priester,
der einsame Frauen
in Opfer verwandelt.
* Er spricht eine Fremdsprache. *
Für uns unvorstellbar,
für Michael nicht.
Wir hoffen nicht,
dass es funktioniert, wir wissen es.
Wir glauben an Voodoo
und seine Macht.
Ich bin überzeugt,
dass es funktioniert.
Nicole Flury
liess sich drei Monate lang
von einem Scammer aus Westafrika
blenden.
Dass alles definitiv ein Schwindel
war, wurde ihr erst bewusst,
als sie Mails von einer
angeblichen Bank in Frankreich bekam,
gespickt mit Fehlern
und ohne Signatur.
Ich sperrte ihn daraufhin
und er versuchte,
mich über gefühlt hunderttausend
andere Nummern zu kontaktieren.
"Lass uns reden!
Das stimmt doch alles nicht."
Ich wollte von all dem
nichts mehr wissen.
Und dann steht man mit zerplatztem
Traum da - Liebe weg, Geld weg -
und fragt sich: "Was jetzt?"
Kein schöner Moment,
wenn man dann hart
auf dem Boden der Realität landet.
Das böse Erwachen,
wie man so schön sagt.
Wie viel Geld sie genau verloren hat,
will sie nicht sagen.
Nur so viel:
einen hohen fünfstelligen Betrag,
also gegen 100'000 Fr.
Das Internet hat die Hemmschwelle
generell gesenkt.
Das Internet schafft eine Distanz
zwischen Tätern und Opfern,
die es Tätern einfacher macht,
ein Delikt zu begehen,
weil es für sie sicherer ist
und weil sie den Opfern
nicht in die Augen blicken müssen.
Die Opfer leben mitunter
auf der anderen Seite der Welt,
z.B. in den Philippinen.
Hi.
Esther Bühlmann
hat mit Angel abgemacht.
Die 15-Jährige geht auf den Strich,
möchte aber aussteigen.
Esther Bühlmann will ihr helfen,
einen Platz in einer Institution
zu finden.
Viele Kinderprostituierte
wurden zu Hause missbraucht.
Die Fälle, in denen dieser Missbrauch
online gestellt wird,
nehmen stark zu.
Erster Halt:
die lokale Polizeistation.
Angel soll u.a. erzählen,
wie es ihr zu Hause ergangen ist.
Die 15-Jährige antwortet ausweichend.
Auf die Frage, ob sie wirklich
in eine Institution wolle,
sagt sie allerdings klar Ja.
Im Moment
scheint sie es ernst zu meinen.
Wenn sie dann mal
in der Institution ist,
morgens aufstehen muss,
um zur Schule zu gehen
und danach Hausaufgaben machen muss,
wird sich zeigen,
wie ernst sie es tatsächlich meint
oder ob sie nach ein paar Tagen
wieder zurückgeht.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass es
mehrere Anläufe brauchen wird.
Die Erfahrung zeigt,
dass der Schritt von der Strasse
in eine Institution
mit festen Strukturen zu gross ist.
Angel unterschreibt ihre Aussage.
Ihren Willen für die Zukunft
hat sie klar ausgedrückt.
In Bezug auf ihre Vergangenheit
bleibt dagegen vieles offen.
Als die Polizistin sie fragte,
ob zu Hause alles gut sei,
sagte sie, dass es mit ihrer Mutter
und dem Stiefvater gut laufe.
Aber mir hatte sie gesagt,
dass sie zu Hause misshandelt würde.
Und Stiefväter gehören
noch ab und zu zu den Tätern -
sei es, dass sie die Kinder
sexuell misshandeln oder schlagen.
Ich weiss nicht,
was genau passiert ist.
Das hat sie mir
noch nicht anvertraut.
Ich hoffe, ich finde es noch heraus.
Aber ich weiss,
dass sie nicht nach Hause möchte,
und dann bringt es nichts,
sie nach Hause zu bringen.
Mit der unterschriebenen Aussage
gehen die beiden zum CSWD,
das philippinische Gegenstück
zur KESB in der Schweiz.
Diese kann nun den Eintritt
in eine Institution verfügen.
Für Angel vielleicht der Anfang
eines neuen Lebens.
Das ist eine Kopie des Briefes,
den sie an die Institution schicken.
Sie schreiben darin ...
... sie würden es sehr empfehlen,
dass sie dort wohnt
und in die Schule geht.
Sobald sie eine Antwort erhalten,
werden sie mich informieren.
Ich hoffe, dass ich sie
nächste Woche hinbringen kann.
Ein Tropfen auf den heissen Stein.
Die Philippinen
sind und bleiben ein Hotspot
für Kindesmissbrauch
und Kinderpornografie,
weil es ein Riesengeschäft ist,
wie Cybercrime generell.
Der totale Deliktsbetrag
ist sehr hoch.
Cybercrime
stellt eine grosse Gefahr dar.
Wir müssen also unsere Kräfte die
nächsten Jahre darauf fokussieren.
Ist die Tendenz denn steigend?
Ja, es ist eine steigende Tendenz -
in der Schweiz
zwischen 20-30 % jährlich.
Philippe Stalder von SRF Investigativ
ist weiter im Darknet unterwegs.
Seine Recherche zeigt:
Hier wird v.a. auch
mit geklauten Daten Geld verdient.
Besonders lukrativ sind für Hacker
Firmen, auch KMUs.
Jedes Unternehmen
mit einer Online-Präsenz
kann Opfer einer Attacke werden.
Sei es, dass Login-Daten im Darknet
geleakt und verkauft werden,
oder dass sensible Unternehmensdaten
verschlüsselt werden,
und für die Entschlüsselung
der Daten Lösegeld gefordert wird.
Ransomware-Attacke nennt sich das.
Eine solche Ransomware-Attacke hat
soeben im Baselbiet stattgefunden.
Die betroffenen Unternehmer
möchten anonym bleiben.
Sie befürchten negative Reaktionen
von Kunden.
Hacker haben die Kontrolle
über ihre Server übernommen
und alle Geschäftsdaten
verschlüsselt.
Nichts ging mehr.
(Mann)
Später kam eine Mitarbeiterin,
die beim Drucker mehrfache Ausdrucke
von der Täterschaft fand,
dass bei uns
Daten verschlüsselt wurden.
Darf ich das mal sehen? Danke.
"Between latw ransomware ..."
Rechtschreibfehler sind auch drin.
"Sie können uns kontaktieren,
um im Darknet gratis
ein Sample der Daten anzuschauen."
Und nahmen Sie danach
Kontakt mit der Täterschaft auf?
Nein,
das überliessen wir der Polizei.
Daten gegen Geld -
das war das Angebot.
Da das KMU regelmässig
Sicherheitskopien aller Daten macht,
musste es nicht darauf eingehen.
Die Gefahren des Internets
seien ihnen bewusst gewesen,
darum hätten sie laufend
in die Sicherheit investiert.
(Mann) Wir waren erschüttert,
dass es uns getroffen hat,
trotz
getroffener Sicherheitsvorkehrungen.
Wie hoch war der Schaden?
Etwa 100'000 Fr.
Der Schaden entstand,
weil sie nicht mehr arbeiten konnten,
bis ihr IT-System neu aufgesetzt war.
Für das KMU war es schon
die zweite Ransomware-Attacke
innerhalb von zwei Jahren.
Bei der ersten führte die Spur
nach Rumänien, nun nach Russland.
Das weiss die Polizei
Basel-Landschaft inzwischen,
mehr noch nicht.
Mehr als 800 Fälle von Cybercrime
wurden im Kanton Basel-Landschaft
im letzten Jahr angezeigt.
Philippe Stalder möchte wissen,
wie viele Täter gefasst worden sind.
Bei Betrugsfällen liegt
die Aufklärungsquote bei etwa 30 %.
Das ist nicht sehr hoch.
In Fällen
von Crypto-Ransomware-Fällen
liegt sie sogar nur
im einstelligen Prozentbereich.
Meistens operiert die Täterschaft
aus Ländern,
die wenig
oder gar keine Rechtshilfe leisten.
Da ist es für uns als Strafverfolger
schwierig, tätig zu werden.
Das erschwert das Ganze.
Oft sind auch schlicht
keine Spuren mehr vorhanden
oder die Täterschaft
vernichtet die Spuren.
Wie fit sind die Kantone
für Cybercrime?
Diese Frage
beschäftigt inzwischen Bundesbern.
Ein Postulat fordert vom Bundesrat,
eine Art Fitnesstest mit
den Kantonspolizeien durchzuführen.
Mein Postulat
ist kein Vorwurf an die Kantone,
dass sie zu wenig machen.
Ich weiss, dass Polizeibudgets
immer unter Druck stehen.
Die Polizei ist diesbezüglich
teils auch Opfer der Politik.
Vielleicht ist das ja ein Weckruf
für die kantonale Politik,
um mehr Ressourcen für den Kampf
gegen Cybercrime zu sprechen.
Sie finden also, dass es dafür
mehr Ressourcen braucht?
Ja, definitiv.
Diese Fälle nehmen zu,
also braucht es
entsprechende Kompetenzen.
Es braucht dafür
Spezialistinnen und Spezialisten.
Es ist wichtig,
dass hier mehr investiert wird
und dass die Polizei auch
für Cyberstraftaten gewappnet ist
und nicht nur
für Straftaten vor Ort.
Es sind über 800 Fälle pro Jahr.
Ihr Team zählt sechs Personen.
Kommen Sie mit der Arbeit nach
oder bräuchten Sie noch mehr Leute?
Wir müssen mit den vorhandenen
Voraussetzungen arbeiten.
Nächstes Jahr
erhalten wir nochmals zwei Stellen.
Dann sind wir zu acht
in diesem Bereich.
Klar, mehr wäre schön,
aber wir machen das Beste
aus den bestehenden Möglichkeiten.
Nicole Flury produziert inzwischen
Videos fürs Internet,
in denen sie andere Frauen
vor Liebesbetrügern warnt.
Im heutigen Video möchte ich
diese Wellenbewegung beschreiben,
die im Love Scamming vorkommt.
Sie will andere aufklären.
Die Tatsache, dass der Mann,
der sie betrogen hat,
nie gefasst wurde,
beschäftige sie nicht mehr.
Ich habe es längst abgehakt.
Ich habe ihm vergeben,
denn es ist mir bewusst geworden,
dass das sein Job ist.
So, wie ich meinem Job nachgehe,
geht er seinem Job nach.
Nicht, dass ich das befürworte,
aber auch er lebt davon.
Ich würde ihm wohl raten,
dass er sich doch bitte einen
anderen Job suchen soll, denn er ...
Die trampeln ja wortwörtlich
über die Seelen anderer Menschen.
Und das ...
Und das kann es nicht sein.
Ich weiss nicht, wie die abends
ruhigen Gewissens schlafen gehen.
Zurück in Ghana.
Das monatliche Einkommen pro Kopf
liegt hier bei 180 Fr.
Michaels Familie hatte nie Geld.
Mit seinen zwei Geschwistern
teilte er sich ein Zimmer.
Eine gute Schulbildung, Karriere -
für ihn keine Option.
In Ghana
musst du gut ausgebildet sein,
um ordentlich bezahlt zu werden.
Meine Familie konnte es mir nicht
ermöglichen, aufs College zu gehen.
Also musste ich
kleine Jobs auf der Strasse machen,
womit man fast nichts verdient.
Deswegen scammen viele: um Geld
für ein gutes Leben zu haben.
Als Liebesbetrüger
lebt Michael sehr gut.
Ich komme gleich wieder.
Hallo.
Ich war vorhin schon mal da und habe
eurem Kollegen Geld gegeben.
Hat er euch das gesagt?
Ich will was ausdrucken.
Zum Schluss
erklärt uns Michael noch mal,
was einen guten Liebesbetrüger
ausmacht -
fast so, als wolle er anderen
den Beruf schmackhaft machen.
Es kommt darauf an,
wie schlau du bist.
Ich habe sechs Monate gebraucht,
um alles zu lernen.
Klientinnen finden,
mit ihnen chatten -
alles in sechs Monaten.
Die meisten brauchen viel mehr Zeit.
Es ist schwer,
jemand anderer zu sein.
Die Lügen, die du erzählen musst,
um Geld zu bekommen -
du musst wirklich gut sein.
Einfach ist es nicht.
Michael bekommt von vier Frauen Geld,
vielleicht bald von einer fünften.
Ans Aufhören
denkt er noch lange nicht.
Stockholm,
die Heimat von Martin Melin,
mit dessen Bildern täglich
Frauen das Herz gebrochen wird.
Er ist zweimal geschieden
und hat zwei Söhne, 13 und 15,
und eine ältere Tochter.
Als ihm klar geworden sei,
dass mit seinen Bildern Frauen
betrogen werden, habe er versucht,
bei Facebook, Tinder, Instagram
und vielen mehr zu intervenieren.
Erfolglos.
Mir sind die Hände gebunden.
Ich bin verzweifelt
oder eher frustriert,
dass niemand
etwas dagegen machen kann.
Ich kann wirklich
nichts dagegen tun, leider.
Und das ist tragisch.
Tragisch.
Viele Frauen, die mit seinen Bildern
betrogen wurden,
suchen den Kontakt zu ihm,
obwohl sie wissen,
dass er nicht der ist,
mit dem sie gechattet haben.
Er regiere mittlerweile kaum noch
auf solche Nachrichten,
sagt Martin Melin, denn ein Austausch
führe schlicht zu nichts.
Viele dieser Frauen, die reingelegt
worden sind, sind in mich verliebt,
in meine Bilder.
Und sie bleiben verliebt in mich
und meine Bilder
und schreiben mir Liebeserklärungen.
Ich glaube, sie wären enttäuscht,
wenn sie merken,
dass ich nicht in sie verliebt bin,
dass die Betrüger
ihnen das nur vorgegaukelt haben.
Nicole Flury, die glaubte, mit
Martin Melin eine Beziehung zu haben,
berät heute Opfer von Liebesbetrug.
Viele fallen in ein tiefes Loch.
Ihr Rat an diese Frauen:
Sein Herz nicht verschliessen
und wegen dieser Erfahrung
nicht auf eine Partnerschaft
verzichten
oder überhaupt keinen Menschen mehr
an sich heranlassen -
es geht ja nicht immer
um einen Liebespartner.
Vielmehr annehmen, was passiert ist
und sich Hilfe holen.
Die Schweiz hat den Kampf gegen die
Kriminalität im Internet aufgenommen.
Aber Philippe Stalders Recherchen
zeigen auch,
mit welchen Gegnern
wir es zu tun haben.
Ich denke, dass in der Schweiz
bereits gute Ansätze vorhanden sind.
Die meisten Kantone haben inzwischen
eine entsprechende Abteilung.
Doch in Anbetracht der Täterschaft
hinkt man sicher immer
einige Schritte hinterher.
Man kann sagen, dass
diese organisierten Gruppierungen
eine sehr hohe Organisationsstruktur
haben.
Sie zeichnen sich
durch eine sehr spezialisierte
Arbeitsteilung aus,
sie sind sehr gut organisiert
und agieren international.
Sie funktionieren
wie normale Firmen -
mit Ferienkalender und Bonussystem.
Zurück auf den Philippinen.
Esther Bühlmann verbringt drei Nächte
pro Woche auf der Gasse.
Bevor sie sich
auf den Weg zum Strassenstrich macht,
muss sie noch einkaufen.
Die Kinder brauchen nicht nur
ein offenes Ohr und Unterstützung,
wenn sie aussteigen wollen.
All jene, die ihre jungen Körper
Nacht für Nacht Freiern feilbieten,
müssen z.B. auch vor Geschlechts-
krankheiten geschützt werden.
Ich habe Kondome
für die Kinder gekauft.
Ich frage sie dann,
ob sie noch welche brauchen.
In der Regel sagen sie Ja.
Ich gebe ihnen je ein Kondom,
denn wenn ich ihnen
den ganzen Pack gebe,
verkaufen sie sie weiter.
Kondome für philippinische Kinder,
finanziert
durch Spenden aus der Schweiz -
das verstehen nicht alle.
Die Kinder würden sowieso anschaffen,
sagt Esther Bühlmann dazu -
entweder geschützt oder ungeschützt.
Für jedes Kind,
das sie vom Strich holt,
stehen am nächsten Tag zwei neue da.
Die Arbeit wird ihr nicht ausgehen,
im Gegenteil,
sie fängt immer wieder von Neuem an.
Ein Junge steht an einem Strand,
wo Tausende von Seesternen
angeschwemmt wurden.
Er wirft einen nach dem anderen
zurück ins Meer.
Da sagt ein Mann zu ihm:
"Das macht keinen Sinn,
es sind zu viele."
Der Junge wirft den nächsten
zurück ins Meer und sagt:
"Für ihn
habe ich den Unterschied gemacht."
Und darum geht es.
Ich kann nicht
die ganze Welt retten,
aber wenn ich das Leben von
ein paar Einzelnen verbessern kann,
habe ich ihre Welt verändert.
Dafür lohnt es sich.
Doch die Welt
werde ich nicht retten können.
Nacht für Nacht
setzt sich Esther Bühlmann
mit einer traurigen Realität
auseinander,
die oft die Folge von Missbrauch
in der Vergangenheit ist.
Verbrechen,
denen offenbar nicht beizukommen ist,
die stetig zunehmen -
auch, weil mit Fotos
und Videos der Übergriffe
im Internet
viel Geld zu verdienen ist.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023